everyone knows tanjiro kamado the main
protagonist of Demon Slayer and one of
the kindest and purest heroes in anime
but the vast majority of people don't
realize the full extent of tanjiro's
power they don't know that he's able to
use elements of four different breathing
Styles and that he and his sister nezuko
possess a secret weapon that can destroy
even muzon himself by the end of this
video you will know the full extent of
all of tanjiro's powers and abilities
including his incredible secret weapon
and the hidden connection between
tanjiro and Demon daddy muzon if you
want to learn all the secret info so
that you can brag to your friends about
being a bigger Demon Slayer fan than
them be sure to watch this video until
the very end you will not be
disappointed you guys know how this
works you leave a quick like and comment
right now and the YouTube algorithm
doesn't destroy me and of course if you
are one of the over 50 of people who
watch our videos regularly but haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet do me a
big favor and make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications subscribing
on YouTube is completely free and it's
the only way to make sure that you're
gonna be notified when we drop more
Demon Slayer videos and I'm telling you
right now we have a lot more content on
Demon Slayer coming very soon finally
this video will contain Demon Slayer
manga spoilers I'm gonna be looking at
all of the relevant information
regarding tanjiro's powers and abilities
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned tanjiro had a very humble
childhood and he never intended to
become an overpowered demon slaying
Warrior he was born on a mountain in a
family of charcoal merchants and the
family lived a simple and Rural Life
tanjiro learned coal burning techniques
from his parents and he helped to carry
and sell charcoal in the town that was
closest to their Mountain Home this
means that tanjiro was exposed to daily
physical labor and physical activity
from an early age which certainly made
him fit and strong but tanjiro never
trained to be a fighter or a sword of
any kind and the only formal training
that he actually got was dance lessons
more specifically tanjiro's father
tanjuro taught him the dance of the fire
god also known as inokami kagura a
ritual dance technique that has been
passed on from father to son within
tanjiro's family for centuries
unbeknownst to tanjiro this ritual dance
actually contained the fundamentals of
sun breathing the original and most
powerful breathing style so even though
he didn't know it tanjiro was in fact
training to become a master swordsman
from a very young age but this dance
training is not the only reason why
tanjiro eventually became so powerful as
we see in the very first episode of the
anime and first chapter of the manga
tanjiro was blessed with some incredible
natural abilities and instincts first we
have his sense of smell that is far
superior to that of an average human and
tanjiro is able to use this to his
Advantage many times times throughout
the story but even more impressive than
his finely honed senses are tanjiro's
excellent instincts in battle and his
phenomenal ability to think
strategically and creatively even in the
most dangerous situations when he first
meets the water hashiragiu after the
tragic death of his family and after
nezuko's transformation into a demon
tanjiro manages to utterly impress giyu
with his combat instincts and his
ability to think on his feet while
tanjiro is trying to prevent gyu from
killing nezuko even though she's been
turned into a demon he figures out
quickly that giyu is much stronger than
him and that he cannot win in a head-on
battle so tanjiro tricks giu by throwing
his Hatchet into the air when Kyu isn't
looking and then he distracts GUI with a
head-on attack while pretending to still
be holding the hatchet in his hand even
though this attack could have led to
tanjiro's death it had the desired
effect and guiyu didn't realize that
tanjiro had already thrown the hatchet
until he was almost hit with it sogiu a
master swordsman and a hashira was just
inches away from being killed by a 16
year old charcoal Merchant with zero
combat experience in the end Geo is so
impressed by both tanjiro and nezuko
that he spares their lives and recruits
them into the Demon Slayer core he is
even willing to stake his own life on
their success because guio agrees to
commit not alive if nezuko ever eats a
human so right from the get-go it is
clear that tanjiro has exceptional
combat instincts and that is only
emphasized further as the story
continues for example when tanjiro is
fighting sekido during the swordsmith
village Arc sekido acknowledges that
tanjiro has great intuition and that he
thinks extremely quickly on his feet
tanjiro is able to evaluate the
situation on the battlefield in an
instant and he intuitively formulates an
incredibly effective strategy like when
he secretly cuts off urogi's foot and
then uses it to block sekido's lightning
attack because he was a able to figure
out that the Demon's own cells are not
affected by the lightning since both
urogi and sekido come from the same
demon they have the same cells and so
the leg of one demon can be used to
pacify an attack by the other tanjiro's
insanely good combat intuition and his
ability to think and act strategically
Under Pressure continue to be an
important theme throughout the story
these combat instincts are not
necessarily something that tanjiro
learned or trained to develop he
possesses them intuitively even before
he undergoes any combat training as we
saw during his first meeting with guiyu
so we have to openly acknowledge that
tanjiro is extremely gifted and
possesses a great deal of natural talent
I don't think he's the most naturally
talented character in the story I would
say that both yorichi and muichiro
surpass him in that regard but
nonetheless tanjiro does have
protagonist levels of natural Talent
this Talent when combined with his
immense determination to save his sister
and with with his truly impressive work
ethic helps to explain how tanjiro is
able to become such a successful Demon
Slayer so quickly the first breathing
style that tanjiro learns is water
breathing and he learns that after six
months of training with gyu's master and
the former water hashira sakonji
urokodaki tanjiro then successfully
passes the final selection and in doing
so he demonstrates not only impressive
swordsmanship skills but also Advanced
acrobatic abilities his strength and
skill advances rapidly after he becomes
a full-fledged Demon Slayer and begins
facing off against stronger and stronger
demons water breathing has 10 different
forms plus an 11th one that was created
by Kiyu but tanjiro doesn't use that one
the first 10 forms include first form
water surface slash which is basically a
single concentrated slash the second
form is water wheel which as the name
suggests involves the user jumping in
the air and spinning in midair in a
circular path in order to create an
attack that resembles a water wheel the
third form is Flowing dance which
involves the user swinging their sword
while mimicking the movements of flowing
water the fourth form is striking tide
which involves using multiple
consecutive slashes while twisting the
user's body in a way that resembles a
powerful water tide the fifth form is
blessed Reign after the drought which
allows the user to kill the Target in a
merciful way so that the enemy will not
suffer this is used on enemies who are
already defeated and helpless the sixth
form is Whirlpool which involves the
user sharply twisting their upper and
lower body and creating a Whirlpool that
will cut through anything in its path
the seventh form is drop Ripple thrust
the fastest technique of the breath of
water style it amounts to a single but
very quick and accurate stab the eighth
form is waterfall Basin a vertical cut
the ninth form is splashing water flow
turbulent which allows the user to adapt
to shape footing by minimizing his
Landing time and the size of the surface
needed to land safely the 10th form is
constant flux a continuous slashing
attack that becomes more powerful with
each new rotation as he becomes stronger
and more skilled with using water
breathing tanjiro actually improves upon
and combines some of these forms in
battle for example he creates second
form improved lateral water wheel which
is an alternate version of second form
water wheel and in which the user
unleashes a horizontal spin instead of a
vertical one there is also Whirlpool
flow which is a combination of third
form flowing dance and sixth form
Whirlpool tanjiro combines the footwork
of flowing dance with the twisting
movements of Whirlpool again the fact
that tanjiro begins to combine and
improve upon some of these forms so soon
after learning to use them speaks to his
natural skill and talent as well as to
his determination and commitment to his
training during his fight against rui
tanjiro finds himself in a desperate
State and facing certain death in that
moment tanjiro realizes that the ritual
dance he learned from his father the
dance of the fire god or the hinokami
kagura can actually be used as a
distinct breathing style and he proceeds
to use it for the first time in battle
as we later learn although still
unprofected at this point in time
tanjiro Sino kamikagura is actually the
original and strongest breathing style
Sun breathing more than 400 years ago
the original user of this breathing
style
yorichitsugikuni demonstrated all of its
forms to tanjiro's ancestor sumioshi
sumiyoshi then passed the forms on to
his children in the form of a ritual
dance and that tradition continued from
generation to generation until it
reached tanjiro himself initially the
hinokamikagura or sun breathing has 12
known forms these include dance which is
a single high-powered slash that comes
down an arc Clear Blue Sky a circular
spinning slash that sees the user rotate
their body to cut at a full 360 degrees
angle Raging Sun an attack composed of a
vertical slash followed by a horizontal
slash burning bones Summer Sun a single
spiraling slash that has both offensive
and defensive properties Setting Sun
transformation in which the user
performs a backflip and then unleashes a
single horizontal slash with the
intention of taking off the opponent's
head solar heat Haze in which the user
rushes forward while hidden in a haze
this Haze hides the true size and
position of the user's sword allowing
them to deliver a surprise attack then
there's beneficent Radiance where the
user spirals upward into the air and
performs a swirling upwards slash
sunflower thrust a single thrust that
uses the tip of the sword to attack the
target Dragon Sun halo dance which
involves the user delivering a bunch of
consecutive slashes in continuous motion
allowing him to strike and decapitate
multiple targets at once Firewheel
involves the user spinning through the
air in order to get behind the opponent
and then delivering a vertical slash in
a circular motion fake rainbow is a
defensive technique that allows the user
to dodge quickly using rapid twists and
rotations this technique will leave
after images and confuse opponents the
last of the 12 initial forms is called
the flame dance which is a combination
of two strikes that starts off with a
vertical slash and then immediately
leads into a second horizontal slash
eventually tanjiro sees the memories of
his ancestor sumioshi directly when he
is knocked out during his fight against
muza and he realizes that some of the
intricacies of the 12 forms were lost to
time and as a result the hinokamikagura
that he learned from his father was not
the perfected form of sun breathing
tanjiro finally Masters all 12 forms
after seeing sumyoshi's memories of Yori
she actually performing all the sun
breathing forms himself tanjiro then
perfects the forms by adjusting the
position of his body as well as his
movements and breathing this makes
tanjiro a lot stronger and more
effective in battle and it also allows
him to discover the secret 13th form of
sun breathing the 13th form was devised
by yorichi for the specific purpose of
defeating muzon by rapidly and
continuously performing all 12 forms of
sun breathing the user is able to
destroy all 12 of muzon's vital organs
his seven hearts and five brains which
are dispersed throughout his demonic
body tanjiro's ability to perfect sun
breathing and unlock the secret 13th
form is crucial for his victory against
muzon but even this is not the full
extent of tanjiro's power when it comes
to breathing Styles yes tanjiro is able
to master both water breathing and Sun
breathing but wait there's more I
already met mentioned that tanjiro has
the incredible ability to modify and
combine different breathing style forms
in order to create new and more
effective attacks and believe it or not
this ability doesn't just stop with his
water and Sun breathing during the
swordsmith village Arc tanjiro creates a
modified version of sun breathing's
first form dance in order to overtake a
fleeing Han Tengu this modified version
is called dancing Flash and it actually
incorporates elements of zenitsu's
Thunder breathing with his own Sun
breathing in particular tanjiro is able
to fuse zenitsu's Thunderclap and Flash
technique with his own dance technique
he inhales a massive amount of oxygen
and circulates it to every fiber of his
muscles and every blood vessel he then
focuses all that blood pumping into his
legs and releases everything all in one
blast that cuts the air like a
Thunderclap by doing this tanjiro
combines the speed of Thunder breathing
with with the phenomenal slashing power
of sun breathing and he demonstrates
that he understands and is able to apply
the technique and philosophy of Thunder
breathing on top of water and Sun
breathing I have no doubt that given
enough time tanjiro would be able to
master and combine all three of these
breathing Styles and that's not even the
end of his breathing style related
Powers but before we get into his final
secret power and his true Ultimate
Weapon let's talk about the other
important techniques and abilities he
possesses techniques and abilities which
complement and enhance his use of
breathing Styles tanjiro awakens the
Demon Slayer Mark which is a Mark that
appears on the body of a Demon Slayer
after certain specific conditions are
met a demon sir who goes through an
extremely tense and life-threatening
situation that sees their heart rate
increase to over 200 beats per minute
and their body's temperature go up to
over 39 degrees Celsius and survives
will be able to unlock the Demon Slayer
mark the mark almost always appears
after the user has been in contact with
other demon Slayers who also awaken the
mark the only known example of someone
being born with the Demon's air Mark
fully formed is yorichi tsukikuni
although there is some question about
the true nature of tanjiro's Mark as
well that's because tanjiro's Mark
appears in the exact location where he
already had what he believed to be a
burn Scar and his Mark actually replaces
this burn Scar the burn scar itself also
changes over time as does tanjiro's
Demon Slayer mark it grows and gets
bigger every time he unlocks it since
tanjiro's Dad had the exact same
quote-unquote burn scar as tanjiro in
the exact same location it is likely
that this was not a regular burn scar in
the first place tanjiro just thought it
was because he happened to get burned in
that same area when he was a kid it is
possible that like yorichi some members
of The Commodore family were actually
born with the Demon Slayer mark But in
their case the Mark was underdeveloped
or unawakened it grows and develops over
time as they themselves grow and develop
and get stronger this part is still
somewhat of a mystery and we don't know
the true nature of the kamado quote
unquote burn scars but my personal
opinion is that yes they were actually
born with a partial or unawakened
version of The Demon Slayer Mark and
that is why tanjiro was able to awaken
it and Trigger that same Awakening in
the other demon Slayers around him now
Awakening the mark act as a major power
boost for every Demon Slayer and that is
certainly the case for tanjiro as well
after he awakens his Mark he becomes
exponentially faster and stronger the
Mark is said to provide increased
resistance against the effects of
muzon's demon blood and The Awakening of
the mark also allows demon Slayers to
attain bright red nietroen blades
turning their blades a bright red color
is essential for demon slayers because
these blades can stop demonic flesh from
regenerating thus these blades are
necessary for defeating the strongest
demons like muzon and the upper Moon
finally demon Slayers who awaken the
mark can also gain access to the
transparent World which is the ability
to see through living bodies as if they
were transparent this allows you to see
the breathing muscle contractions joint
movements and blood flow of the person
you are looking at and that in turn
allows you to track and predict their
movements being able to access the
transparent World also increases the
speed and reaction time of the user
because it allows them to see the world
around them as if it was moving in slow
motion but even though the Demon Slayer
Mark enables the Demon Slayer to attain
incredible new power-ups there is a
catch the immense power that comes with
the Demon Slayer Mark comes at the cost
of the demon slayer's lifespan every
Demon Slayer who manifested the mark
dies before the age of 25. although
there is one one known exception yorichi
who was born with the Mark didn't die at
age 25. in fact he lived well into his
80s and he continued to fight demons
until the very end of his life because
tangido may have actually been born with
an underdeveloped or unawakened Mark
that started to manifest progressively
over time it's possible that he too like
yorichi could live well into his 80s and
even this is not the end of tanjiro's
many powers and abilities during the
hashira training Arc tanjiro learns a
technique called repetitive action which
is also practiced by genya and the stone
hashira gyome himejima basically you
repeatedly perform a predetermined
action such as a religious chant in
order to heighten your concentration to
the extreme and this enables you to
fully open up all five of your senses
you then summon a memory of anger or
pain which increases your heart rate and
body temperature along you to draw out
the full physical power of your body
shifting back and forth from repetitive
action to exerting your full strength
allows you to perform a superhuman
physical Feats such as moving a gigantic
Boulder this technique is separate from
breathing Styles but some Demon Slayers
are able to use both techniques at the
same time which helps them to unlock the
Demon Slayer Mark and maintain it for a
longer period of time during his fight
against upper moon to akasa in the
infinity Castle tanjiro unlocks the
state of anata which is also known as
the state of not self or the selfless
State the individual who attains this
state has no detectable fighting Spirit
meaning that they give off absolutely no
malicious intent or intent to kill
during a fight akasa Compares fighting
someone in this state to finding a plant
and it is impossible to predict the
individual's movements based on their
malicious intent akasa had always
strived to attain such a state himself
and before tanjiro he had never met any
human who didn't have a fighting spirit
that he could detect akasa senses that
he must kill tanjiro right away because
he has now become simply too dangerous
if akaza doesn't kill tanjiro now he
will surely be killed by him in the end
tanjiro's ability to essentially erase
his presence and enter this selfless
State plays a key role in allowing him
to come out on top in the fight against
akaza and now let's talk about the good
stuff tanjiro's biggest and most
controversial power-up let's talk about
Demon King tanjiro in chapter 201 as the
fight against muzon is finally coming to
an end muzon realizes that his body is
about to disintegrate in the sunlight
and that he is about to die but before
he dies he injects what's left of his
demon blood into a dying tanjiro muzan
is hoping that by consuming his blood
tanjiro will also inherit muzan's will
and become the next king of the Demons
the one who is destined to finally
conquer the Sun and destroy the Demon
Slayer core muzan's decision to inject
tanjiro with his blood saves tanjiro's
life but it also turns tanjiro into the
ultimate demon demon king tanjiro muzan
believes that as a demon tanjiro is the
chosen one the perfect demon and the
ultimate living creature that's because
on the one hand he is the only person
since yorichi who was able to fully
Master Sun breathing the ultimate
breathing style and on the other hand as
a demon tanjiro is able to conquer the
sun which is something that muzan has
been trying to do for 1 000 years but
never managed to accomplish
anticipated that as a demon tanjiro
would be able to conquer the sun because
his own sister nezuko was already able
to do that at the end of The swordsmith
Village Arc and that is why we need to
briefly talk about nezuko because she
plays an important role in unlocking
tanjiro's full power
the first time that tanjiro's nitrogen
blade turns red is during his fight with
Han Tengu and it happens because nezuko
uses her pyrokinetic blood demon art on
his sword this is an early hint that
tanjiro and nezuku are strongest when
they work together although we had even
earlier examples of this in the story
including the fight against rui nezuko
is an incredibly unique demon a demon
who was able to resist eating humans and
whose blood demon art is harmful only to
other demons despite the fact that she
is herself a demon nezuko clearly has
absolutely immense willpower and her
determination to help Humanity despite
being a demon is truly remarkable but
nezuku's ability to develop a resistance
to sunlight to become immune to the sun
despite being a demon is what truly sets
her apart as I mentioned earlier even
muzon the progenitor of the demons and
the strongest demon in the world was
unable to achieve this so once he learns
about nezuko's incredible feat he
decides that there is something special
about her and her bloodline and he
believes that tanjiro as her brother
will also conquer the sun once he
becomes a demon which is exactly what
ends up happening muzan's belief that
demon king tanjiro would become the
ultimate creature proved to be
absolutely correct as a demon tanjiro
has no weaknesses he conquers the sun
almost immediately and the red nitrogen
blades are ineffective against him Kiyu
even says that there's no way to
actually kill tanjiro he's just too
powerful you should have felt that Demon
King tanjiro had the potential to
surpass both muzon and yorichi and
become the strongest creature in
existence he has the strongest
regeneration abilities of any demon in
history making him practically
impossible to kill the sun is not a
factor and he has practically unlimited
endurance and stamina
Demon King tanjiro also instantly
develops his own blood demon art which
allows him to alter his flesh in a
similar way that muzan himself was able
to do for example he can grow huge
bone-like tentacles and whips from his
back and use them against his opponents
he can also unleash powerful energy
blasts from his mouth in what looks like
something right out of Dragon Ball and
in general demon tanjiro is an absolute
monster there is no way that anyone
would have been able to defeat him if he
had stayed a demon but as we know
tanjiro decided to fight against muzan
and his demon influence from the inside
and eventually he won and went back to
being human personally I thought that
this part in the manga was really rushed
and I wish that we got to see more of
demon king tanjiro before he reverted
back to being human I wish there was an
entire extra Arc that featured tanjiro
going through an epic internal struggle
while learning to live as a demon and
maybe the villain of that Arc could have
been like other demons that we haven't
met yet like for example demons who
moved to other countries at some point
in the past and became extremely
powerful without anyone in Japan being
aware of it if we had gotten this extra
Arc we would have been able to see the
ultimate power in the entire series a
secret weapon that only tanjiro would be
able to unlock
Demon Sun breathing in the Demon Slayer
story we have two known examples of
demon Slayers who go on to become
powerful demons kaigaku who becomes
upper Moon 6 after daki and gyutaro are
defeated and kokushibu who became upper
moonwan kaigaku is a user of Thunder
breathing and once he becomes a demon
his blood demon art enhances and
transforms his Thunder breathing
abilities so once he becomes a demon not
only can he still do normal Thunder
breathing but he also has the ability to
generate black lightning from his body
and use it in battle this lightning will
burn the Flesh of his opponents during a
fight making kaikaku's attacks much
stronger than they were back when he was
human moment his Thunder breathing
technique becomes faster and more
powerful and the range of his attacks
also improves dramatically it's Thunder
breathing but boosted and enhanced by
additional magic demon powers as a Demon
Slayer upper Moon one kokushibo was a
user of moon breathing which is arguably
the second strongest breathing style
after sun breathing just like kaigaku
kokushiba's blood demon art greatly
enhances and boosts the power of His
original breathing style allowing him to
generate Crescent Moon shaped blades and
sickles and launch them at his opponents
these blades change their size length
and shape on a regular basis making them
incredibly tricky to defend against
kokushiba's blood demon art also allows
him to create a flesh Katana a Nigerian
sword enhanced with demonic powers
this sword is more powerful and durable
than a regular sword it can transform
itself in order to add even more blades
to it or to change its size and shape
and kokushibo can even generate multiple
additional flash blades from his body
basically turning himself into a demonic
Katana porcupine I think these
demonically enhanced sword breathing
powers are extremely interesting
especially when we consider the fact
that had tanjiro remained a demon he
could have created a demonically
enhanced version of the strongest
breathing style of all Sun breathing
just imagine demon tanjiro using Sun
breathing as he is swinging his sword
and immense dark Flames are spreading
all around him and scorching everything
in sight imagine if his Sun breathing
transformed into like black hole
breathing allowing him to manipulate
gravity itself and pull everyone and
everything towards him just to then burn
them up with his demonic dark fire with
an ability like this on top of all his
other powers tanjan will no longer be
Demon King tanjiro he would truly become
demon god tanjiro the strongest being to
ever exist in the history of the Demon
Slayer world I have to admit that it
would have been really cool to see this
happen even if only briefly I mean
tanjiro is the protagonist and an
extremely kind person he was always
going to go back to the light side of
the force eventually but it would have
been awesome to have seen him grapple
with the dark side just a little bit
longer what do you guys think about
demon god tanjiro and what would his
demonic Sun breathing look like and how
would it function would he be able to
use multiple demonic breathing Styles
including demonic water breathing or
maybe even demonic Thunder breathing hit
me up with your thoughts down in the
comments below if you're looking for an
epic Demon Slayer video to watch next
check out this video on tanjiro's
shocking Family secret Link in the
description and on screen if you enjoyed
this video and you want to see more
demon star content in the future leave a
quick like right now and if you're one
of the over 50 of people who watch our
videos but haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a big favor and make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification Bell to turn on
all notifications